what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
right now one of the most exciting
things happening in the mcu is doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
the illuminati patrick stewart's
professor xavier was teased in
multiverse of madness the official
trailer for it and the illuminati as
well and this opens up everything
endless possibilities this brings the
x-men into the mcu it could bring the
fantastic four in and we have a good
idea of who the illuminati will be and
we know that superior iron man is going
to be one of those members now i
realized by now that this person who was
glowing probably isn't superior iron man
but is most likely either captain marvel
who is actually maria rambo or is maybe
a variant of kang the conqueror maybe
even iron lad but either way we do know
that superior iron man is going to be in
the movie because of the ultron bots
that are escorting doctor strange to the
illuminati and this is actually pretty
crazy if you think about this this means
that a variant of iron man succeeded in
a different universe at putting a suit
of armor around the world and is now
part of the illuminati since they are
using his ultron bots and now instead of
having the bots around the world he has
them around the multiverse but who
exactly is superior iron man well i
actually believe that he could be one of
the villains of multiverse of madness
and i believe that he is going to fight
wanda or i guess i should say the
scarlet witch so let's talk about what
happened in his universe before that
made this variant of iron man become
somewhat evil and become superior iron
man and of course if you're new be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos now the first thing you
should know about superior iron man is
that he is truly an evil iron man now
it's not 100 his fault these events took
place during the axis event in which the
morality of earth's heroes and villains
were reversed this was done by magic and
eventually the spell was reversed again
but tony stark was shielded from this so
he remained evil from here of course a
lot of heroes opposed him and one of
those biggest ones was pepper potts but
unfortunately nobody could really stop
him he grew into a huge egotistical
monster he took over huge huge companies
by force and basically brainwashed the
entire population and turned them into
drug addicts he created an app that
everybody had on their phone that they
would get addicted to and then would
have to pay a hundred dollars a day to
upgrade then he used his bots to
essentially enforce whatever he wanted
to enforce so essentially he became a
tyrant and took over everything now of
course in the mcu we have to talk about
what all the fans have been talking
about recently tom cruise playing
superior iron man now i'm definitely
here for this although it is just a
rumor right now and is basically what
fans want but for a very good reason
marvel originally wanted tom cruise to
play iron man before robert downey jr
however tom cruise turned down the role
believing that the role wouldn't work
marvel was interested in robert downey
jr but he was in a lot of trouble at the
time but luckily for us tom cruise
turned it down and marvel knew what they
were doing and robert downey jr became
the perfect iron man but in a world our
world if the multiverse was real
technically there would be another
universe where tom cruise did indeed
accept that part and became iron man and
that's essentially what we want to see
in the multiverse of madness a variant
of tony stark who is actually played by
tom cruise who is superior iron man but
what would his story be what would have
happened in that other universe for him
to become superior iron man and i will
talk about his suit because this is
important for some things that we've
seen in the trailer but first let's go
over the story like i mentioned this is
somewhat more of an evil iron man so how
would that happen how would tony start
kind of go down this evil path well i
personally think that things would have
kind of gone down a similar trajectory
that happened with our iron man until
one big thing happened pepper died i
think in this other universe pepper died
this is the key to tony stark turning
evil she was killed maybe by somebody
like loki or maybe she was actually
killed in iron man 3 instead of getting
the extremists but this is extremely
important because pepper is the one who
kept tony grounded and she loved him the
most and she was the reason he kind of
stayed down to earth and he was already
pretty egotistical to begin with but she
kind of brought him back down and made
him realize that other things were more
important in life so he loses her and he
loses control and he becomes determined
to kill any threat at any cost and take
full control over earth's safety this is
where he succeeds in putting a suit of
armor around the world because now he is
more determined now logic won't really
work for him now he's not really going
to listen to what anybody else has to
tell him because he doesn't care all he
cares about is that he could have saved
her if he had put a suit of armor around
the world he could have saved pepper so
he's taking it into his own hands now so
he puts a suit of armor around the world
and this leads to him obtaining infinity
stones now here's where the suit of
armor comes into play the superior iron
man suit is the indo-sim armor and it's
a fully liquid smart metal this suit is
basically a symbiote like venom it's
entirely liquid and once it gets to the
human body it hardens not only that but
it has a psionic connection to tony
stark he can feel the suit and control
it with his mind he can literally make a
armor bot out of it without even
touching it and there's no technology
involved in controlling it he simply
feels it so it's pretty much a symbiote
except it is not alive on its own it is
only connected to tony but this armor
would allow tony stark to actually wield
infinity stones and use them as weapons
which is what i believe will happen tony
starts getting infinity stones from some
of these villains on earth he gets the
mind stone from the scepter he
eventually goes on to get the space
stone from the tesseract or from thanos
when he comes to earth because the
events of the first avengers film most
likely did still happen thanos is still
coming to earth but tony is going to
defeat him in an instant this would also
give him the power stone thanos is
strong but with an iron legion of bots
and a liquid indo-sim suit tony stark
and his legion beats thanos so now tony
has an iron legion of bots around the
world and he has three infinity stones
this is where the illuminati comes in
now there are two different things that
could happen here either the illuminati
finds him and wants him to be a part of
the illuminati or he creates the
illuminati himself the illuminati would
want superior iron man because he's rich
he has infinity stones and he has the
ultron bots that could help surveil the
multiverse so he's a very powerful
person at this point and it would make
sense that they would want him to join
especially if they feared that he might
actually be evil it's better to have him
on their team than to actually be evil
but perhaps this could be actually more
personal for superior iron man perhaps
this is part of his multiversal
domination maybe superior iron man
formed the illuminati maybe he did this
so he could not only control the world
but control the entire multiverse total
domination total control his bots across
not just earth but multiple earths
multiple different universes superior
iron man has a god complex in fact one
of his most famous lines is i'm the most
intelligent capable person on the planet
i'm not playing god all this time i've
been playing human basically saying that
he is a god he's just been plain a human
and what better way to feel like a god
than to control the entire multiverse so
i think he has major ulterior motives
here on the illuminati and i think this
is why a fight breaks up between the
scarlet witch doctor strange and the
illuminati because he's going to be
somewhat hostile now the scarlet witch
is going to be as well which is why the
two of them will most likely fight and
as i mentioned in my video yesterday i
think he's going to lose i think the
scarlet witch is going to kill all of
them if not every one of them but mordo
so i think he's secretly a villain but
unfortunately i don't think he's gonna
have that much time to shine because the
scarlet witch is going to kill him but
let me know what you think about this
theory in the comments down below let me
know if you think that this is what
superior iron man's life could have been
like in his universe and this could
somewhat be his origin story i truly
hope we see something like this in the
multiverse of madness get a little bit
of a backstory about some members of the
illuminati but we'll see in the meantime
don't forget to subscribe for more
videos don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof